EPA Administrator Scott Pruett is out
Trump rallies in Montana and we check
the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
many a new day will meet my eye many
much news will find me okay in any case
we were going to talk all the news we're
gonna get into the mailbag but first I
want to remind you that our national
debt right now is 21 trillion dollars in
counting why do I remind you of this
well because the money that we now owe
other countries is greater than the
entire economic output of the United
States if your entire life savings is
tied to the US dollar you should ask
yourself a question what is your plan
for Hyper and play inflation
particularly if the left decides that it
wants to blow out spending even more
hedge against inflation and hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
some precious metals gold is a safe
haven against uncertainty now I'm not
saying you should take all your money
and stick it in gold but I'm saying that
my savings plan is diversified and yours
should be to the company I trust with
precious metal purchases Birch gold
group and right now thanks to a little
in the IRS tax law you can even move
your IRA or eligible 401k into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver it's
perfect for people who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from any future geopolitical uncertainty
look back historically when the bottom
falls out of everything else Gold tends
to safeguard savings Birch gold group
are the folks you should trust they have
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau
yomo about Birch Gold's free information
kit for a limited time qualified
purchases can earn up to an additional
10 grand in precious metals for free
through July 31st to find out if you
qualify contact Birch gold now go to
birchgold.com slash been talk to one of
their reps mention I sent you that's
birchgold.com slash ben's do it now
the offer only runs until July 31st
terms and limitations apply ask your
sales representative for details ok so
the big news of the day is that EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt is out and I
want to begin by saying that Scott
Pruett totally deserves to be out so a
lot of people are coming to scott pruett
defense they're suggesting that he was
unfairly targeted they were pointing out
the EPA under Barack Obama was
scandal-ridden yes that's true the EPA
under Barack Obama was indeed
scandal-ridden I remember when they
turned an entire River in Colorado
yellow remember that they were trying to
get rid of some waste and so they blew
up a barrier in the in the place that
was holding the waste and infused an
entire River with his bright yellow
copper tinged gunk it was great you know
the EPA under Barack Obama was a
disaster that said was scott pruett on
the up and up a lot of people out there
defending scott pruett today saying that
Scott Pruett was on the up and up it was
all targeted well if that's the case
then you have to wonder why is it that
the only Trump administration officials
who have been for sale or forced out
actual reasons of corruption like Tom
Price over at the Health and Human
Services desk or Scott Pruett over at
EPA like they haven't found anything on
general mattis over a Department of
Defense they haven't found anything on
Mike Pompeo over at state even Rex
Tillerson was there and he wasn't a good
Secretary of State they had nothing on
Rex Tillerson and there a lot of folks
who are who are defending Scott Pruett
today saying that he was just targeted
because he was such a do-gooder over at
the EPA reducing regulations but the guy
who is going to be replacing him andrew
wheeler is going to be just as activist
from what I understand Donald Trump
tweeted out I've accepted the
resignation of Scott Pruett as the
administrator of the Environmental
Protection Agency within the agency
Scott has done an outstanding job and I
will always be thankful to him for this
the Senate confirms at PDPA Andrew
Wheeler will on Monday assumed duties as
the Acting Administrator of the EPA I
have no doubt and he will continue on
with our great and lasting EPA agenda we
have made tremendous progress in the
future of the EPA was bright well his
resignation letter to Donald Trump is
appropriately obsequious I mean it is
supremely obsequious
and Trump is a big Trump defender he's a
big Prewitt defender specifically
because Pruitt is big Trump defender so
Pruett wrote in his letter quote it is
extremely difficult for me to see
serving you in this role first because I
counted as a blessing to be serving you
in any capacity but also because of the
transformative work that is occurring
however the unrelenting attacks on me
personally my family are unprecedented
and have taken a sizable toll on all of
us the talk from inside the
administration is that pearl is actually
forced out this was not him saying that
he wanted to go the president says that
printed an outstanding job inside the
EPA so here's just a list of the
scandals that led to Scott Pruett
stepping down because there's a lot of
talk about Pruett being unfairly
targeted here I mean it ain't it ain't
great so number one Pruett fired an aide
after she refused to alter appointments
on his calendar so an EPA scheduler was
asked to delete and change information
about past events on Pruitt's schedule
which could be potentially a violation
of federal law since you're not allowed
to go back retroactively Leigh and
change what was on your schedule
EPA lawyers made the aide aware that
altering records may be illegal this is
fortune.com reporting Scott Pruett asked
his staff to find his wife a job with a
salary of at least $200,000 which is not
an appropriate use of government staff
she also reportedly agreed that provided
asked subordinates to perform personal
work this is according to Samantha
Draven former EPA policy administrator
she told congressional and
the Gators that Pruitt had asked her to
help find Pruitt's wife a job and the
salary should be at least 200 grand
scott pruett used official channels to
try to get a chick-fil-a franchise for
his wife which is real weird since you
can just apply to get a chick-fil-a
franchise he used a secret email address
instead of official ones even after the
Hillary Clinton email scandal he used a
loophole to award staff raises without
White House knowledge right this of
course was very controversial at the
time the White House told Pruitt he
couldn't offer high salaries to two of
his closest aides but then he used a
loophole in the Safe Drinking Water Act
to boost their wages according to the
Atlantic he rented a Washington DC
apartment at a steep discount from a
lobbyist he apparently rented this
apartment at 50 bucks a night in
Washington DC it was supposedly owned by
the wife in a couple who are both
lobbyists her husband represented
clients had matters in front of the EPA
he chartered a lots of flights
he flew first class he had a $43,000
soundproof phone booth installed in his
office suggesting that there are just
too many people attempting to spy on him
he ordered a unprecedented security
detail he was saying there are threats
against him which may or may not have
been true and there are a bunch of other
issues with scott pruett
and thus he had to step down are any of
these you know fireable in and of
themselves probably not when you
aggregate them all together it doesn't
look good for Scott Pruitt and that is
why Scott Pruitt is out today and
appropriately he should be again his
resignation letter explains why it is
that that Scott Pruitt was such a
favorite of President Trump he said mr.
president it has been an honor to serve
you in the cabinet as administrator of
the EPA truly your confidence in me has
blessed me personally and enabled me to
advance your agenda beyond what anyone
anticipated at the beginning of your
administration your courage
steadfastness and resolute commitment to
get results for the American people both
with regards to improved environmental
outcomes as well as historical
regulatory reform is in fact occurring
it is an unprecedented pace and I thank
you for the opportunity to serve you and
the American people in helping achieve
those ends that is why it is hard for me
to advise you I am stepping down as
administrator of the EPA my desire and
service to you has always been to bless
you as you make important decisions for
the American people I believe you are
serving as president today because of
God's providence
I believe that same Providence brought
me into your service I pray as I have
served you that I've blessed you and
enabled you to effectively lead the
American people blessing and serving and
serving and blessing and blessing and
serving and blessing and serving so
there's there's a reason that Scott
Pruett was it was a favorite of
president Trump's he did by the way what
he did in terms of regulatory reform at
the EPA I agree with a lot of that stuff
but
comes to being a swamp creature it's
pretty clear that Scott Pruitt
unfortunately was one of them and that's
why he had to go there's a reason that
Laura Ingraham for example was
suggesting that Scott Pruitt had to go
now with all of this said the suggestion
from the media is that the White House
is in turmoil again
Scott Pruett is out it's just a constant
it's a constant episode of Survivor over
at the White House this is this is the
cover of the New York Daily News they
they said the same thing they're
basically showing all the members of the
Trump administration on the front page
and then it exit out Scott Pruett its
head out right and said that this was
Trump's version of Survivor season two
okay so what so there's lots of turnover
the real question is is the policy
getting done for the American people now
I will acknowledge that the perception
of instability about the administration
is not useful it is not good right the
fact is that one of the things the
Democrats are counting on with regard to
2020 particularly is a feeling of
general unease about president Trump's
administration a feeling that just in
general things are up in the air too
much there there's a lot of that well
that's not great but is the policy
getting done the answer is the policy is
getting done the the policy continues to
be quite good other than tariff policy
the economy continues to grow report
today from the Department of Labor total
nonfarm payroll employment increased by
two hundred thirteen thousand in June
the unemployment rate rose to four
percent but the unemployment rate
increase was only because more people
are getting back into the workforce
because finally the economy is really is
really moving job growth occurred in
professional and business services
manufacturing in health care while
retail trade lost jobs total nonfarm
payroll increased two hundred thirteen
thousand in june has run by 2.4 million
over the last 12 months employment in
professional and business services
increased by fifty thousand in june has
risen by about five hundred and twenty
one thousand over the year manufacturing
added 36,000 jobs in june these are very
good numbers for the President of the
United States very good numbers for the
country the participation rates have
shown some improvement labor
participation rates there's a lot of
talk during the Obama administration
that a lot of people had dropped out of
the workforce those people are now
starting to come back the workforce
participation rate ticked up two-tenths
to sixty two point nine percent that's
still slightly lower than sixty three
percent in February it's well below the
post great recession rate of sixty five
point seven percent and it's near the
post great recession rate bottom of
sixty two point six percent according to
Ed Morrissey over at hot air but at
least it's moved in the right direction
and the employment population ratio is
still at sixty point four percent which
is still a very low rate we need more
people employed but the fact the
unemployment rate went up is actually
good news because more people are
getting back into the workforce looking
for work again
there's also slow wage growth but that
makes sense because when only six and
ten people are working there's a lot of
people who are still entering the job
market creating competition that makes
that that creates pressure for a
lowering of the wages so now all of this
is good economic news now all of this is
is excellent economic news and President
Trump has a right to be proud of it
president Trump has a right to be proud
of the the economy that he has helped to
foster here now with that said we are we
are looking at more tariffs now you know
the the reason that President Trump is
is I think undermining his own economy
is with with his tariffs talk so now
President Trump is firing the biggest
shot yet in the global trade war
according to the economic times by
imposing tariffs on thirty four billion
dollars of Chinese imports delivering on
a promise to his political supporters
that risks provoking retaliation and
harming the world economy so as I have
said many times before when it comes to
tariff policy I have no problem
whatsoever with the President of the
United States using tariffs as a tool to
lower tariffs in other countries if he
is using tariffs as a ratchet if the
idea here is that there's a tariff on
our product somewhere else and we're
putting a tariff on their products here
and now let's lower all the tariffs
that's fine but the president seems to
have a peculiar fondness for tariffs he
thinks that trade wars are easy to win
well it turns out the trade wars are in
fact it not easy to win China is also
increasing tariffs and the EU has
increased tariffs and Mexico has
increased tariffs after months of
rhetoric a twenty five percent levy on
thirty four billion dollars of Chinese
goods entering the United States took
effect just after midnight on Wednesday
on Friday sorry with farm and Claussen
and airplane parts among the products
targeted according to Bloomberg trying
to hit back immediately via duties on US
shipments including soybeans and
automobiles which is not good for the
United States economy Trump is already
looking at another sixteen billion
dollars of Chinese goods suggesting the
final total could top top 500 billion
dollars more than the u.s. bought in
2017 the Chinese commerce ministry is
accusing the United States of bullying
and in the knighting the largest trade
war in economic history now is this
going to be good for all the people he's
going to need to win in 2020 I don't see
how I mean there are a lot of soybean
farmers who are going to be damaged
by the fact that China is now putting
new tariffs on all of this now there's
still a lot of folks saying this is not
showing a lot of trade fairs hurting the
United States economy but we have not
seen this play out yet there's there's a
report yesterday that folks are holding
back capital that there are new reports
from the Fed suggesting the businesses
are holding back capital investment
because they're perturbed about the
future of this trade war under a
full-blown trade war according to
Bloomberg in which the u.s. slaps 10%
tariffs on all of the countries and they
respond economists reckon US growth
would slow by 0.8 percentage points in
2020 Trump has already imposed duties on
foreign steel and aluminum imports
drawing a response from the EU and
Canada which fret he may go after
automakers next so none of this is a
particularly good policy but we will
find out whether whether it continues to
spiral or whether everybody seems to
back down because there's another report
yesterday that suggests that China was
going to lower its tariffs a little bit
which would suggest that president
Trump's strength on tariff policy may be
a good thing so we'll talk about that in
just a second first I want to talk a
little bit about your underwear because
the fact is that it is getting hot out
there and the last thing that you need
are uncomfortable underwear in the hot
weather this is why you need Tommy
John's check out the underwear from
Tommy John's the revolutionary clothing
brand that has redefined comfort for
people everywhere including me only
Tommy John combines the latest in fabric
technology with patented wedgie proof
designs for a fit so perfect it's almost
like wearing nothing at all the Leger
proof design would have come in very
handy for me back in high school and you
will never have to worry about
swamp-like conditions below because
Tommy John's moisture wicking fabrics
pull perspiration right off the body so
it's like 110 degrees here in LA today I
mean it is extraordinarily hot here
today I am very grateful that I'm
wearing Tommy John they're cool cotton
fabric tries four to five times faster
and keeps you 2 to 3 times cooler than
traditional cotton plus all Tommy John
underwear is backed by the best pair you
will ever wear or it's free guarantee so
you don't have anything to lose stay
cool and collected all summer long with
Tommy John no adjustment needed hurry -
Tommy John comm / Shapiro and you get
20% off your first order that's Tommy
John comm / apparel for 20% off again
that's Tommy John comm / apparel let
them know that we sent you and again you
will ensure that Tommy John's
gets you those underwear at 20% off your
first order when you use that promo code
Shapiro so all of that check that out ok
so is is any of this going to be good
for the US economy well the dollar has
been knocked so that's not good
according to the according to the
Financial Times what we are looking at
right now the possibility of a trade war
is going to have an impact on the
strength of the United States dollar
according to according to Andrew
Milligan who's the head of Global
Strategy at Aberdeen standard
investments with so many mixed messages
coming out of Washington it may be a
relief for investors to focus on hard
data such as Fed minutes and payrolls
report the combination should reinsure
investors that whatever the travails of
some emerging markets the US economy
remains in robust shape China's stocks
found support Wall Street equities
indices are holding steady and European
bourses are drifting lower and cautious
trade as investors tracked the latest
round of in of the international trade
dispute so the the US dollar was knocked
a little bit it lifted Wall Street
futures back over flat line and pushed
Treasuries lower you know the economic
reports continue to be good the dollar
index is down 0.5% sentiment is so
cautious after the increase in the
tariffs there still seems to be a lot of
wonderment in the markets at all of this
there's still a lot of talk in the
markets about the idea that perhaps none
of this will will come to pass that
perhaps these tariffs will be back down
by Congress perhaps everybody will back
away take the hands off the triggers I
hope that that happens I also don't
understand why Congress isn't stepping
in and reasserting its trade Authority I
don't think the president no matter
which party should have this much trade
authority it's why I thought the TPP
should have been ratified through the
Senate it should not have been a
situation where TPP was being signed off
on by the presidents of the United
States all treaty should be ratified by
the Senate the Senate should have the
power to look over any sort of tariff
arrangements the presidents of the
United States is making it was not
granted under article 2 of the
Constitution or the presidential power
does not include foreign commerce that
is under the legislative power the idea
that the president can unilaterally
decide tariff rates seems to me foolish
and counterproductive if the president
wants to can you continue strengthening
the economy now with all that said the
media continue to do an awful job of
covering the Trump administration so
yesterday there was a report from The
Associated Press and it made all the
rounds and the headline was really
disturbing and when I first saw the
headline I too was disturbed here is the
headline US Army quietly discharging
immigrant recruits so if you just read
that headline from the AP you would
assume that the US Army was quietly
discharging on immigrant recruits and
they were seeking out people who are
immigrants or illegal immigrants who
joined the Army for citizenship and then
trying to dismiss them out of some sort
of misguided xenophobia
but that's not actually what the article
says and it turns out that's not the way
that any of this works according to the
AP some immigrant US Army reservists and
recruits who enlisted in the military
with a promise path to citizenship are
being abruptly discharged The Associated
Press has learned the AP was unable to
quantify how many men and women who
enlisted through the special recruitment
program have been booted from the Army
but immigration attorneys say they know
of more than 40 who have been discharged
or whose status had become questionable
jeopardizing their future okay so let's
start with the statistics here there's
70,000 members of the United States
military who are immigrants the AP has
tracked down 40 and said these 40 are
now being discharged and they say this
is because of xenophobia you might
wonder why they're not going after all
70,000 if this is really about
xenophobia the answer is because it's
not about xenophobia according to AP
some of the service members said they
were not told why they were discharged
others who pressed for answers said the
army informed them they'd been labeled
as security risks because they have
relatives abroad or because the Defense
Department had not completed background
checks on them here's the way this works
when you go and you sign up for the
military you are now technically a
recruit but you have not gone through
basic training and if you have not gone
through basic training that is because
they've not completed the background
check on you so if you sign up and it
turns out that you were once a drug
runner for ms-13 you're going to be
rejected from the Army or now an
immigrant recruit rejected under the AP
Stalley but the AP is attempting to
create the perception that there is a
widespread Trump administration policy
to get rid of immigrants in the United
States military which by any stretch of
the imagination would be a ridiculous
policy if it existed but it doesn't
exist because that's not what's
happening here
eligible recruits are required to have
legal status in the US such as a student
visa before enlisting more than 5,000
immigrants were recruited ins of the
program in 2016 an estimated 10,000 are
currently serving most go to the army
some also go to other military branches
according to the AP to become citizens
the service members need an honorable
service designation which can come up
after even just a few days of boot camp
but the recently discharged service
members have had their basic training
delayed so they can't actually be
naturalized so again is this really just
evil terrible horrible or is this the
Defense Department doing exactly what
they're supposed to do the Defense
Department says all service members ie
contract it recruits active duty Guard
Reserve and those with an honorable
discharge are protected from deportation
so this is not you know again this is
dramatic misreporting
on a wild level so CBS and News
analyst Mike Lyons actually debunked
this he's former West Point grad he said
some immigrant US Army reservists and
recruits who enlisted in the military
with a promise path citizenship are
being abruptly discharged The Associated
Press has learned but he says that this
is not the case right he says that this
is this is an exaggeration
he says the story is not framed properly
this happens to natural-born citizen sue
I know many u.s. citizens weren't
allowed to start basic because a bad
background check came back Lyons noted
that one of many possible reasons why a
recruit might not make it to boot camp
is because they didn't complete
background checks it could be a myriad
of reasons clearances failed physicals
bad background checks which eliminate
natural-born citizens as well the Army
in particular needs people there's
another side to this story that's not
being told Lyons says AP reporters quote
failed to get the other side of the
story or sized the issue compared to
everyone who enlisted there's a good
reason they are tonight entering basic
training center for security policies
Michael Waller explains the murderous
immigrant gang known as ms-13 has
infiltrated the US Army as well he says
the US has corrected has charged such
people and any other security risks
luckily the US military has a lot of
foreign-born recruits who had immensely
to our capabilities so that everybody
sort of jumped to conclusions on this
because this is what happens the media
create these false headlines and then
everybody jumps to conclusions based on
the false headline and then it turns out
they're simply not true a retired Army
lieutenant colonel Margaret stock who
created the so called military
accessions vital to the national
interest program has opposed the the
fact that this was combined with the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program under then President Barack
Obama right this created additional
security screenings for those waiting in
the MAVNI pipeline right the military
accessions vitals in the national
interest pipeline kernel stock
lieutenant colonel stock she said the
decisions apparently Avenue with daca
sounded like the death knell for the
program because mavin II was never
intended as a way to address the hot
potato of political citizenship for
undocumented long-term residents
she says they made a colossal error
frankly instead of trying to recruit the
daca separately they tried to shove the
jakka's into the MAVNI program and that
happened to wreck
both programs so just just brilliant
stuff there by the AP and of course
brilliant stuff there from the Obama
administration as per the usual
arrangement now in just a second I have
to tell you the stupidest story of the
day it is an incredibly stupid story and
you will love it because it is just that
stupid but first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at bowl and branch so
we're never
agree on everything but the one thing we
can agree on is that none of us are
getting enough sleep well one of the
reasons you may not be getting enough
sleep is because your sheets are
uncomfortable I know you don't think
that your sheets all that often you went
to one of these local retail shops you
picked up some sheets you didn't think
about much after that but then every
night you're sweating through the sheets
and you're thinking why is this so
uncomfortable
well that's what bull and branch is here
to cure you can buy directly from them
so you're essentially paying wholesale
prices they are made from pure 100%
organic cotton it means that bull and
branch products start out super soft
they get even softer over time luxury
sheets can cost up to a thousand bucks
in the store bull and branch sheets are
only a couple of hundred bucks you think
that's expensive for sheets it really
isn't it's really cheap for luxury
sheets more than that it's really
comfortable and you're in those sheets
every single night so why wouldn't you
actually want to get something nice
everyone who tries bull and branch
sheets loves them we've we have them at
our house not only do we have them we
got rid of all of our other sheets
they're so good that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep on bull and
branch sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but
you're not gonna want to send them back
to get started right now my listeners
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets at bull and branch com promo code
man that's bull and branch calm Bo LL
and branch calm promo code Ben for 50
bucks off your first set of sheets go
check it out right now
bull and branch comp promo code Ben get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets
okay so when the derangement on the left
is a source of great amusement - I think
a lot of people as well it should be
because it's hilarious this is the is
the best article of this kind I have
seen in a long time and I've been
reading a lot of these lately okay this
is the actual title of a real article
this is not fake this is not pretend
it's by a woman named Bridget Delaney
Bridget Zeleny in the UK Guardian
writing on Independence Day one of the
reasons this article may be one of the
reasons we declared independence from
Britain she said Bridget Delaney writes
I stopped going to the gym because of
Trump now I can't open jars that is the
actual title of the piece and she's
serious because it's fantastic
so here is what Bridget Delaney writes
it was November 2016 the only person I
knew who believed Trump would win the
u.s. election was the owner of my gym
this was clearly a ridiculous prediction
so seeing the chance for some easy money
I offered about him a hundred bucks that
Hillary would win now the gym owner
clearly not wanting to do his dough
pointed at this horrible thing in the
corner with the name sled and said if
Trump wins you have to pull 70 kilograms
on it it was double what I could usually
pull and if I won the bet the gym owner
would pull it taut we'll pull double his
person
best I didn't want Trump to win he grabs
a woman by the bleep and mocked a
reporter's disability he promised to
build a wall and called Mexicans rapists
the thought of his presidency was
frightening but so was pulling the sled
what if I herniated disc after Trump
claimed victory I went to the gym in a
foul mood just effing load up the effing
sled alright let's get it over with I
said with that much grace as I strapped
a belt around my waist
I pulled the sled like a human oxen
while being filmed it would be like a
human ox actually and the gym staff
cheered but I did it the Trump victory
soured my successful show of strength
yeah I could pull a pretend sled but how
is that gonna help me when the world had
been destroyed by nuclear weapons or
climate change not kidding actual
article from The Guardian hungry and
sore I repaired to a restaurant down the
road I had never visited and where I'd
never seen anyone come or go from the
silent restaurant no background music no
other diner seemed like the perfect
place to welcome the end of the global
liberal order what new political order
had been born tonight an elderly waiter
appeared and handed me a menu most
things on it were not available the one
dish that was unspeakably awful and the
color and texture of cement was
available I never went back but I also
didn't return to the gym I associated it
now with Donald Trump the bad meal and
pulling the sled it was November 9th to
set 2016 and my thinking about Fitness
changed almost overnight in tune with
the times it became more Trump less
Obama Trump explained his exercise
routine like this to Reuters I get
exercise I mean I walk I this I that I
run over to the building next door I get
more exercise than people think well I
walked I this I that months passed then
a year Trump was going to be in power
another 2,000 years or at least that's
when it felt like rights this this crazy
person Bridget Delaney and then she
continues could I really avoid the gym
for the entirety of his presidency I
missed being strong enough to open jars
and carry groceries
so last week I returned to the gym
slinking back in as if no time had
passed I hope that by wearing a puffy
jacket and MC Hammer pants I could hide
my lack of definition then I could
pretend I'd maintain Fitness on my own
at home running to the building next
door on the couch while tweeting but you
can't hide fitness either have it or you
don't
you can either lift the dumbbell or you
can wobble on your fifth rep and drop
the load you're either strong or you are
weak and I was weak I was fit in 2016
before Trump when you stop it goes and
it goes quickly a week or two and you
have to start again with the two
kilogram dumbbells and the tremor in
your forearms I return again this week
to the boredom and pain of
Jim trying to build up back to the
strength I had before Trump became
president
the struggle is Sisyphean that's a real
article that happened in real life in
the world yeah yeah I have a feeling
some people can't handle the fact that
Trump became president yeah that
impression because um they crazy okay so
that it's speaking of the crazy so an
actual older gentleman decided that it
was necessary to assault a teenager who
was wearing a mag I had so this is just
wonderful as a teenager in Texas who
went to a water burger restaurant and
he's wearing a man he went like 2 a.m.
and this guy who's working at the at the
water burger decided to go over rip the
mag a hat over this guy's head and then
throw a drink on him here's a little bit
of what it sounded like right now police
are looking for that man it was caught
on tape on camera throwing a drink at a
teenager in that video the man in the
red hat and walks off with the teenagers
hat pulled it off so aggressively he
also pulled out some hair with it ok so
there there's just a charming charming
fellow his name is Kino Jimenez he's a
bartender in San Antonio's he's a genius
and maybe he'll be hit in Congress I
mean who knows bartenders for Congress
is like a new thing apparently and and
he is now he is he has now been arrested
and he will probably do some jail time
or at least in probation time but as
well he should the part of all of this
that's that's hilarious that there were
seriously a bunch of people on the Left
who decided that it was worthwhile
supporting all of this rather than so
for example Marc Lamont Hill came out
and he suggested support for the mag AHA
stripping guy he said that it's just
terrible that that this guy was arrested
so he tweeted out that there's a guy
named I guess Ben laughing I don't know
who that is
he says wish I could take the high road
but I'm your manga hat reads like a
swastika to me so um hmm yeah maybe I'm
no longer a decent person yeah you're no
longer a decent person right if they
have somebody wearing a Hillary hat and
I said that Hillary hat stands for
abortion on demand the murder of the
unborn and then I took that person's hat
and I threw a soda on them you'd think I
was jerk because I would be a jerk mark
Lamont Hill tweeted back a bunch of
crying laughing emojis because it's so
funny then he says he still I actually
don't advocate throwing drinks on people
not at all but yes I think Magga hats
deliberately reflect a movement that
conjures racism homophobia xenophobia
etc so yes it's a little harder to feel
sympathy when someone gets coca-cola
thrown on him so in other words I don't
condone throwing drinks some people but
I sort of condone throwing drinks on
people well you wonder why President
Trump is so popular with the base the
reason is because president Trump's
basic attitude toward the world is F all
these people and that's his basic
attitude toward the world and when you
hear Michael Eric Dyson a professor at I
think Georgetown talking about how
Republicans are all racists you get the
appeal for a lot of Trump supporters
Michael Eric Dyson going crazy on CNN as
per his usual routine Martin Luther King
jr. said it's not the white supremacist
who are the problem it's white moderates
and conservatives whose tend to be
complicit with that by trying to dismiss
it
brother Jennings much respect for you
but this is ludicrous what you're doing
is even more egregious because you're
attempting to justify legitimate and
make valid what are essentially naked
raw statements of racism and until white
folk like you can stand up and find your
spine you will continue to be complicit
in the racist animus of this country
they suffer for all of the people who
actually voted for President Trump or
all the people who plan on voting for
President Trump and for all the people
who are doing so because they think the
Democrats are nuts and because they like
Trump on policy being called a racist is
actually not all that pleasant it's the
worst thing you can call somebody in
American life as my mentor Andrew
Breitbart used to say calling people
racist just because you disagree with
them on policy or because they support a
politician you don't like is a pretty
astonishing charge and it's one of the
reasons why Trump is so all-fired
popular right now it's because he goes
to rallies and he doesn't seem to care
he just goes and he says what he wants
to say and that has some serious appeal
for a lot of folks on the right so
President Trump was rallying in Montana
and Great Falls Montana Trump obviously
loves this stuff so I was on Fox News
yesterday and I was supposed to be on at
the time the president was speaking
which means they they push you off until
President Trump is done speaking because
he's the president and they like to
cover his rallies which makes perfect
sense
so Trump goes on and on he went for an
hour and 12 minutes yesterday at this
rally in Great Falls Montana which is
extraordinarily long for the president
and it's a long comedy routine right
everything that he does is basically a
long comedy routine is really really
funny it's really a reverence half the
stuff he says is not strictly speaking
true but a lot of it is is really
driving and powerful and trumpet is
is he punches back I mean this is why
they love him you get the people saying
I can't open a jar any more because I
want to exercise thanks to trump and you
get people saying that they're gonna rip
hats off teenagers heads and you have
people saying that all Republicans are
racist and it comes off as kind of
refreshing when the president of the
United States is willing to get down in
the mud and input and punch a little bit
here's the President of the United
States going after the protester who
decided to climb the Statue of Liberty
clip six I would have said let's get
some Nets and let's wait till she comes
to just get some nets you see those guys
to bravery of doing that okay honestly
all right like I know you should I be
upset that he said they shouldn't go up
and rescue the lady she wanted to be up
there so I don't really see the problem
I kind of agree with him I'm not sure
why anybody should risk their life we'll
get some nuts up there well get like how
about we we should just surround the
Statue of Liberty with bounce houses and
the lady can jump down on to bounce
houses so you wonder why people like
Trump that's why people like Trump and
there was more like this right it's just
the this is the best part of it he goes
after Elizabeth Warren those are the
Warren of course has been virtually
signaling some people Charlie cook is
saying he thinks she's the frontrunner
for 2020 which would be a huge mistake
by Democrats Elizabeth Warren is Hillary
Clinton part to accept less charming and
Elizabeth Warren wants to run and she's
been you know virtue signaling all over
the place she's really awful she's I
mean I had her as I didn't have her as a
professor at Harvard Law but I was at
Harvard Law when she was a professor
there she was not well liked shall we
say among those of us on the right or
those of us who just didn't like people
who were kind of mean generally but she
but Trump goes after her because of her
fake Native American ancestry this is
just spectacular
let's say I'm debating Pocahontas right
and in the middle of the debate when she
proclaims that she's of Indian heritage
because her mother said she has high
cheekbones I will give you a million
dollars to your favorite charity paid
for by Trump if you take the test and it
shows you're an Indian you know
now is that actually gonna happen no but
Elizabeth Warren no she's not Native
American that's the part that's
hysterical so she tweeted out well
Donald Trump wants to give DNA tests to
everyone to me to immigrant children at
the border first of all the emigrant
children at the border being given DNA
test you know the reason they're given
DNA test it's to determine that the
people who say they're their parents are
actually their parents
that's legitimately why they're given
DNA tests at the border because we want
to make sure that it's not human
smugglers who are trying to bring
children in for human trafficking but I
love that Elizabeth Warren tries to
Reese just to swivel off of the fact
that she's not Native American but
continues to claim Native American
ancestry Megan you gotta love the guy
when he says this kind of stuff
maybe that that's that's really funny
stuff okay I have a little bit more on
that plus I want to get to the mailbag
first we're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire comm you're gonna have to
subscribe for $9.99 a month to get the
rest of this show live and it can be
part of our mailbag you can get your
questions answered today when we have
our events like we have big events
coming up in Dallas and Phoenix get your
tickets now because they are running out
at daily wire.com slash events if you
are a subscriber you would have first
access to the VIP tickets and those are
the people who we actually get to hang
out backstage and become best friends
and go fishing together and everything
it's gonna be great
but you get to when you're a subscriber
you get all of those privileges also you
get the rest of Andrew Clavin show live
the rest of michael Knowles's show live
when you become the annual subscriber
ninety-nine bucks a year you get this be
very greatest in all beverage vessels
leftist ears hot or cold tumblr look at
it behold its glory and when you
subscribe at youtube or itunes once you
can do for free you also get to be but
you also get to see our sunday special
this sunday special this week is pretty
awesome sam harris stopped by we talked
religion and God and the Bible and
atheism and all sorts of goodies so go
check that out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so president Trump's entire instinct
always is to punch back and the time
when the left is so aggressive and they
were so aggressive with Mitt Romney you
know the it's it's loved by the base and
I see why it is loved by the base it's
something that in 2011 actually I wrote
a column about Donald Trump you know
before I was not a fan of Donald Trump
in 2015 in 2011 I wrote a column about
Donald Trump in which I said that he had
a few money and a nephew attitude and
it's why he might be the only person
who'd beat Barack Obama in 2012 I was
right in 2011 because that is the thing
people like about Donald Trump and so
long as the left continues to play
directly into his hands by being as
Extreme as humanly possible he is going
to continue to succeed along these lines
okay let's do the mailbag let's get into
some of your questions today so Cameron
says dear Ben can you tell us the origin
of The Daily wire did you and Jeremy
boring meet secretly in the Hollywood
Hills under the pale moonlight Slayer
plans where the two of you doused with
cosmic rays transforming him into the
lowercase G lowercase K God king and you
into the bringer of leftist years and
more specifically did you ever consider
being anything other than a strictly
conservative outlet so he says that we
might consider hiring liberals and
branching out to become more of an
objective newsroom so the story of how
Daily wire came to be is that Jeremy
boring and I have been good friends for
eight years and business partners for
approximately five now four or five
years so Jeremy and I started truth
revolt together which was a subset of
David Horowitz freedom center when truth
revolt was defunded then we decided to
move on and we had a plan for truth
revolt that we had plans on doing inside
the David Horowitz freedom Center and
instead we took it to our funders and
our funders liked the plan they looked
at it they said that they're willing to
get behind it and that's how daily water
began it really was essentially that
simple there are some really good
stories surrounding the formation of the
company there are you know people who
there there was one particular group
that didn't understand our business plan
that we talked to and I won't mention
the group because a little embarrassing
for them considering you know how well
the company thank God has done but one
there was it there was it was an older
group of people and I was trying to
explain to them exactly how the company
would how the company would operate how
we would actually make our money and as
I was explaining them how we were gonna
spend a lot of money on social media
marketing and how that was going to
translate into traffic for our website
and how's this in turn would generate
more money that we could use for social
media marketing and all the rest and
they seriously didn't get it they said
can we can you make that simpler and I
said yes and I took out a napkin and I
took a pen and I wrote a dollar sign
arrow Facebook arrow website arrow back
to dollar side that's the entire
business plan needless to say that did
that meeting did not go well but there
wasn't it but eventually we got our
funding at one of the funding meetings
there's a very funny story where I was I
was meeting with a funder and more than
the funders a billionaire said something
like well you know we have a lot of
people come in here and and those people
you know asked constantly for money and
they all have very similar business
plans they all they all want to get into
sort of conservative media so you know
what MIT what makes you what what makes
you so special and I said well I'm
better at this than any of them and he
started laughing and that that meeting
did go well so yeah you never know
what's gonna work in a business meeting
all I will say is that sometimes being
brash helps you and sometimes being
brash hurts you as far as whether we are
interested in moving into a more
objective news coverage than I'm happy
to have debates on the site with people
on the left I'd be happy to do point
counterpoint right and left on dayley
where I think that would actually be
kind of fun as far as I reportage I'm
not gonna report from the left because I
think the left is wrong okay Michael
says Ben if you're president who are
some people you would want its advisors
and want Thomas solo on economics I
would probably want on foreign policy
both both John Bolton and maybe Angela
coda via from just for a difference of
opinion at Claremont Institute I think
that you know on on some of the kind of
domestic political issues dana perino
would be great she really knows the ins
and outs there are a lot of really great
people Veronica says how can we get
Republican officials to understand and
stand up for conservative values rather
than caving to Democrat bullying and
doing just enough to get reelected who
are our new GOP leaders well the truth
is that virtually everybody who elect
has a set of incentives and that set of
incentives is to do just enough to get
reelected the only way to stop them from
doing that is that you do have two
primary people who you think are not
doing enough as far as new GOP leaders
they're all from solid red states so I
think that Mike Lee is a solid GOP
leader he's from Utah he feels safe and
that means that he has the capacity to
really push but tug and pull of national
politics is
I'll admit is very difficult my job is a
lot easier than their job I get to sit
here and say exactly what I think what I
think is right a lot of these folks are
trying to balance staying in office to
to prevent Democrats from being in
office and getting things done but if
you're in a swing district from New York
it's not quite the same thing as being
in the solid red state like Utah would I
prefer more conservative leadership out
of Republicans in Congress you bet I
would do I think we can get more I do I
think that McConnell has been stalwart
on enough issues no but with that said I
think that we ought to give our
legislators a little more credit than to
think that they're all quite as cynical
as we make them out to be sometimes in
the talk radio business Canyon says dear
Benton what is your opinion on a
convention of states I know the late
Justice Scalia had a negative view of
the idea and voices concerns I don't see
any other way to pass amendments that
would repeal the 16th amendment and
Institute a fair tax for example thanks
love the show I'm a fan of the
convention of states I think the
convention of states is a fine idea I
know there are lots of concerns about a
quote unquote runaway convention where
people just start proposing random ideas
and suddenly they are being ratified by
the states but anything that you pass
the convention of state still has to be
ratified by the states so I don't really
see how that is going to happen so I'm
fine with the idea of a convention of
states I think it's quite a good idea
the article five convention of states
Mora says the Supreme Court ruled last
week non-union members cannot be
compelled to pay union dues to unions
they do not support do you believe this
ruling can challenge the constitutional
constitutionality of the Obamacare
individual mandate well the answer is no
the reason the answer is no is because
the Obamacare individual mandate has
been held to be a tax not a fine right
has not been held to be their finding
you to force you to buy it's been held
to be a tax in lieu of you buying okay
that is not what the statute says that
is why the Obamacare decision is a
travesty of justice it has nothing to do
the actual text of the of the Obamacare
bill it's one of the reasons why I'm
very skeptical about judge Kavanagh
who's now being considered for the
Supreme Court by President Trump because
in his opinion at the DC Circuit Court
level he tried to avoid jurisdiction on
Obamacare altogether by claiming that it
was a tax rather than a fine if it were
considered a fine it would have been
ruled unconstitutional on his face
probably Michael says hey Ben I was
wondering about how you classify someone
as being evil I believe someone can
commit evil acts and not be evil but at
what point do the bad decisions firmly
become who you are well you know I would
say that as a general rule calling
individual human beings evil unless they
are clearly you know in the evil
category or
or Hitler or something calling human
beings evil is a difficult thing to do
unless they are actually a murderer or a
rapist if you're a murderer or a rapist
I have a feeling that we can call you
evil with a pretty fair bit of
confidence I don't think that we have to
worry too much about you
you know actually being a good person if
you're a murderer or a rapist if however
you are just a person who has shoplift
at once right you're a person who did
something you're an alcoholic when you
were young and then and you're abusive
to people and then you got over it and
you and you repented are you wholly evil
you know that Maimonides has a basic
view of this and that is that there are
people who we consider good we're their
good deeds outweigh their bad deeds and
there are people who we consider evil
we're their bad deeds outweigh their
good deeds and then they're the bait own
eating right the people who are sort of
in-between and this raises a bunch of
questions which is like okay well are
you only in the middle one you have
exactly the same number of sins as as
merits basically the answer is no the
answer is that you have to consider
yourself basically a person in the
middle your entire life the minute you
consider yourself good you're likely to
do evil the minute you're you consider
yourself evil you are likely to do evil
so you should consider yourself as a
person who's always walking that fine
razor sharp edge between good and evil
and this will keep you on the straight
and narrow but generally we should be we
should be and analyzing the acts of
human beings rather than character as a
general rule Ryan says Ben very often
say this is not what the founders
intended does that mean you think there
was no sort of intellectual progress
since the United States was founded no
of course there's been intellectual
progress since the United States was
founded on a wide variety of issues but
there has been no end of intellectual
progress on eternal truths regarding the
nature of human beings in fact I think
there's been very little development
intellectually on on eternal truths
regarding human beings for thousands of
years I think human nature has been
pretty well understood by great
philosophers and great poets and great
thinkers for thousands of years I don't
think much has changed among human
beings and I think the attempt to play
human nature as intensely malleable has
been one of the great causes of
suffering in the last two centuries
rachel says do you think the tariffs
will last what I mean what it means to
business is both small and large
resource materials components or sub
assemblies from China to be built into
final products here I doubt the tariffs
will last I think there's probably a
short-term thing I hope it's a
short-term thing if it's not I hope the
Congress steps in and stops it but
obviously it's gonna raise costs for
inputs for businesses in the United
States who use Chinese product and this
the idea that it doesn't damage American
businesses in any way to put tariffs on
Chinese goods that are being important
to the United States is just it it's
economically foolish Dustin says what do
you think the odds are the Ginsberg or
Breyer retired in 2020 to try and get
more Democrats out to vote also can you
make Knowles wear a wig so people don't
think I'm watching Maddow it's
embarrassing
well I can't I can I can barely get
Knowles to wear a shirt so you know
getting him to wear wig I think might be
a little bit much as far as the odds
that Ginsburg or Breyer retire in 2020
no way they are not retiring in 2020
they'll retire in 2021 if a Democrat is
elected and they will retire never if
Donald Trump is reelected they'll stay
as long as a Republican is in power I
don't think they want to risk their
seats with the possibility of an
incumbent winning particularly because
incumbents have such a good record in
presidential elections Elyse says hi Ben
you are frequently asked about the
future of the Republican Party what do
you think the future of the Democratic
Party is how radical do you think it
will become in the future
well the Democratic Party has been
moving steadily more radical and now
exponentially more radical over the past
several years I think they're going to
embrace full scale Bernie Sanders
democratic socialism I think you're
gonna see them embrace Medicare for all
I think you're going to see them embrace
see them embrace full scale
nationalization of particular industries
I think you're going to see them embrace
a just blowout in government spending I
think that you're going to see them
embrace virtually all the planks of
Bernie Sanders platform a right to
housing a right to health care a right
to free college education I think all of
this is on the table for Democrats and I
think they're not going to quit with
their intersectional nonsense because
they see that as the as the spine of
their support base so you're gonna see a
mash-up between the two worst elements
of the Democratic Party the socialism
and the intersectional identity politics
kyles has been I went to a high school
just outside of the Madison area in
Wisconsin during our study of the Great
Depression we were taught that Hoover
did not believe in government
intervention in the markets and because
of this the depression lasted longer
than it had to is there any merits of
this statement no this is one of the
great lies in American history one of
the great lies in American history is
that Hoover Herbert Hoover was a was a
fellow who deeply believed in the free
markets that is revisionist history
Herbert Hoover according to members
seriously according to members of the
FDR administration Herbert Hoover was a
person who attempted to implement
virtually everything virtually
everything that Democrats eventually
attempted to implement seriously like
this is it's such an amazing and
nonsensical and stupid argument that
Herbert Hoover
was a was an emissary of the right when
it came to policy in 1930 Hoover imposed
smoot-hawley Tariff that was leftist
policy which crippled global trade
global trade dropped a small fraction of
what had been he blew out the federal
budget in 1929 the federal budget was
3.1 billion dollars by 1932 he'd
increased in nearly 50% in real dollars
Hoover doubled the federal budget since
the Great Depression came along with
deflation his deficits ran higher than
FDR's did all the way until World War
two Hoover participated in subsidies to
agriculture on a massive scale he tried
to pressure firms not to cut workers and
wages he forced the government to pay
above market wages for federal projects
he pursued government-sponsored loans to
States and banks he pressed enormous tax
increases right this is Herbert Herbert
Hoover quote we met the situations with
proposals to private business and the
Congress of the most gigantic program of
economic defense and counter-attack ever
evolved in the history of the Republic
this is a member of FDR's brain trust
according to Steven Horowitz quote when
we all burst in to Washington we found
essentially every idea of the New Deal
enacted in the 108th Congress in the
Hoover day in the Hoover administration
itself so yes this is all a lie it's
just not true ok fine let's see a couple
more questions Ryan says King Benjamin
of the house Shapiro king of the
Conservatives and the first men have one
inquiry of you your grace what is your
opinion on term limits for Congress
Supreme Court and governors thank you
for your time and consideration your
grace long may you reign well I'm in
favor of term limits for Supreme Court
justices I think the idea of having
lifetime appointments has outlived its
usefulness considering that people are
sitting on the court for 50 60 years and
it turns into this ghoulish Death Watch
having a rotation it seems to me
perfectly reasonable having an 18 or 20
year term seems to me just fine as far
as elected positions I'm not in favor of
term limits I think you should be
elected as much as you want in in any
elected capacity and you use the
incumbents get thrown out more and more
frequently these days it seems so I
think that it makes a lot of sense for
for us to leave the no term term limits
rule in place if people can't handle it
that's their own problem it's a
democracy okay so it's time for a couple
of things that I like and then a couple
of things that I hate so things I like
this is not a good movie okay it's not a
good movie but it is an enjoyable movie
the movie is death wish
now the original death which I think
have I endorsed it have I had the
original death wish as a thing I liked
on the show before I haven't
okay the original death wish is a
fantastic movie the Charles Bronson
death wish is a great movie was made
during the 1970s in the heyday of New
York being an absolute crapple New York
being a high crime awful place to live
where time scores basically a giant dung
heap okay and that movie is great
because it's Charles Bronson and
basically the plot of the movie is that
these two dogs one of them I believe is
Jeff Goldblum like very very young Jeff
Goldblum they break into his apartment
and they rape his wife and daughter and
kill his wife and leave his daughter
basically catatonic and he is this kind
of soft-spoken architect and he and
bereft he just starts basically
wandering the streets and one day he
tries to confront somebody gets beaten
up by a criminal he's literally the the
movie is literally a liberal mug by
reality
and then the next time he goes out he
takes a roll of quarters in a sock and
somebody tries to mug him he turns
around it hits the guy in the face with
it and then he goes out and gets a gun
and he starts basically gunning down
every criminal he can find and the room
crime rate in New York City begins to
plummet because criminals are suddenly
afraid they're going to be shot and
people all over the city start to say
okay well if I'm gonna be mugged I'm
gonna fight back and the city doesn't
know what to do because on the one hand
they've got this vigilante who is just
going out and shooting criminals and on
the other hand the crime rate is
dropping precipitously and so the
original movie is really good and super
politically incorrect there's there's
even a scene in the original Death Wish
from the nineteen seventies with Bronson
where Bronson is walking through a party
and people are all talking about him
right there know who he is but they're
talking about the vigilante and and
there's this conversation going on where
somebody says I think it's a black
person says well I think he's racist
because he's disproportionately shooting
black people and the person answers well
maybe there should be fewer black
criminals and then he wouldn't have to
shoot as many black people basically
I mean it's supremely politically
incorrect my goodness
so the original death which is a good
movie the new version with Eli Roth is
not nearly as good they turn it into
sort of a a fugitive Death Wish mashup
in which it's a deliberate targeting of
his home it's a deliberate robbery and
he ends up basically tracking down the
people who did this stuff to his wife
and his daughter but it is enjoyable
moment less I mean there's full-scale
scenes devoted to him learning how to
use a gun learning how guns work
watching videos on YouTube on how to
clean and disassemble a gun learn it
going to
gun shop where there's like this very
busty blonde this kind of upbeat busty
blonde has explained me about guns work
is just great and and it's got some
really gory horrific scenes but is it's
not as good as the original Death Wish
but the fact that left hates it so much
it's simply because the movie is pro-gun
and an anti-crime it really is that
simple so here's a little bit of preview
[Music]
I'm sorry dr. Z nothing yet so there's
nothing that I can do is that what
you're saying
can I have faith had faith work out for
them
if a man really wants to protect sports
his he has to do is for himself okay so
you can see why conservatives would like
this film right now so this is the film
is good the film is it well it's not
good it's not a good film it's an
enjoyable film so go check it out also
Bruce Willis is just fun and everything
oh man this scene right here woohoo yeah
it gets really ugly really quickly so um
yeah that what happens right there is a
not pleasant
so okay time for a couple of things that
I hate
all right so I think I hate number one
Bill Clinton says that he has done his
penance right he's asked on The Daily
Show they're gonna continue to try it
out Bill Clinton the left and they're
going to continue to offer him
opportunities to pretend that he
actually did penance uh regarding his
sexual infidelities and sexual
perversions and proclivities during the
1990s and he's gonna continue lying
about it here's what he said on Comedy
Central but left to let him get away
with this obviously we're all trying to
work our way through not all of us but
most of us are trying to wake our way
through how we can use this moment to
build a better country in person after
person after person's life and that
should be the number one priority of
everybody that's what we should be how
we should think about this me too moment
this is a we can't waste it we've got to
do better we gotta do better I love
having Bill Clinton lecture all of us on
me too dude you were credibly alleged to
have raped a woman and you're incredibly
alleged to have sexually abused several
women and now he's sitting there I my
favorite part of all these interviews is
just the James Patterson who co-authored
this novel with him has to sit there and
and deal with it like James Patterson
who's probably the best-selling author
of all time he's sitting there just
looking like you every single interview
he looks like depressed Mitch McConnell
like he just wants to crawl into a hole
and just lie there for a while it's
pretty spectacular
so yeah would the left ever allow Donald
Trump to get away with this stuff of
course not but Bill Clinton will allow
him to get away with it continuously
because they all worship at the altar
because he supports abortion and all of
their political agenda okay I have to
show you one more thing that I hate but
also kind of love so this is thanks to
Colton Colton is one of the people he's
Employee of the Month here at Daily wire
a prestigious title that comes along
with a little note that goes in a frame
but Colton was walking around the office
showing this to people which begs the
question is what he's doing in his off
hours but apparently he saw this this
tape on YouTube and decided that I had
to see it apparently there is something
called ponying that happens I guess this
is in New Orleans which apparently is a
weird place and let's just play it
because there are very few words that
can describe what's happening here we're
out here having a pony play competition
where people compete in events and
classes just the same as
real hoard is a pony fetish festival
these Pony play hobbyists in New Orleans
Louisiana dress up and compete in
showjumping events dressed from head to
toe in horse gear into what they call
pony face ponies people that once they
put the gear on that actually turn into
horses when I put the bit in his mouth
it's like a ritual between us
he needs that transition to get into
headspace and I can feel through the
when he actually kind of changes
from a human space to like plenty space
before we take him out in for the
reining competition during playing if I
just put him in the gear yeah and then
we go immediately do it hmm it doesn't
give him time to transition into him
headspace that allows him to express
himself okay so just to be clear folks
if you're not watching this it's not
just that they are dressed up in like
full-on horse suits they are not they're
dressed up in basically the suit
from from pulp fiction dressed as ponies
in suits walking around competing
kicking carts yeah so here's the thing
here's the thing Ken will who are we to
judge can we judge and who are we to say
that these people are not actual ponies
that's the real question they've entered
the ponies face they are now ponies so
you know here's the real question you
know if they say that our Pony who are
you to say they are not a pony who are
you who are you to find them what makes
you so systemin what makes you what why
can't they go by their preferred
pronouns right they can be neigh who
knows any pronoun they choose why not
who how dare you sir
how dare you madam how dare she you know
you that this these are legitimate
ponies these are just as real as the
ponies that you would see at a ranch
somewhere okay and if they choose to run
out there with the ponies if they choose
to poop in the field
and if they choose if they choose to use
bit and bridle well then that is their
problem and you sitting there laughing
at them judging at them they don't need
your scorn there in your scorn your
booing is what is causing them their
suffering it is it is you do you
understand it is your fault you it's
society's intolerance that creates these
sorts of situations where beautiful
stunning poetic horses like this have to
be they have to be let let free only far
from the city why can't they live among
us why can't we have beautiful pristine
animals creatures of God like this among
us in the city why not we need or cesare
all part of our lives
why ok so you know I think that it's uh
I would also say that there is a sad
side to to pony space so the sad side to
pony space is that when they break their
legs you have to shoot them and that's
that's the real sad side here because
you know if they were human and they
broken leg you just take them to the
hospital but if they're if they're in
the pony space when they break their
legs they cannot be healed there are now
ponies and you actually have to put them
down for their own sake because the legs
are not going to heal I mean I suppose
you could try to do like they did with
that racehorse a few years ago and likes
to set suspend them in a pool for a
month or something but are they really
worth the trouble most horses are not
running at the Kentucky Derby so I don't
know but this is it's it's very you know
it's disturbing that we would be so
intolerant that we wouldn't take them
seriously that we would not take their
hobbies seriously you know these are
olives they say they have to be vanilla
upright citizens Monday through Friday
so to get out and pretend to be
something else is so much fun but
they're not pretending even this woman
doesn't understand the reality of the
pony space understand the reality of the
pony space respect the pony space and if
you've seen one of these ponies on the
street out of the goodness of your heart
give them a carrot and a lump of sugar
well we'll be back here next week with
all the latest updates presumably not
from pony space because what the living
and we will have all the updates from
the Supreme Court but storms gonna be
back here on Monday making his Supreme
Court decision I believe Monday night so
we'll be here for that this is the Ben
Shapiro show and I am Ben Shapiro thrown
off by the pony spaceman just thrown off
by the pony space the Ben Shapiro show
is produced by Senya Villarreal
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austen Stevens edited by Alex and
Garo audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair
and makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018